[Music]  the goddess of death destroyed your  hammer like a piece of glass  [Music]  go near a colon  quite unique was made from this special  metal from the heartwood dying star  every time I threw it you always come  back to me I could harness lightning  make energy blots and when I spun it  really really fast it gave me the  ability to fly  [Music]  you murder Hema no I didn't write down  the hemorrhoid you on your back no no I  spin it really fast it would pull me off  but oh my god the ground would pull me  off the ground up into the air and I  would fly sounds like you had a pretty  special and intimate relationship with  this hammer and then losing that was  almost comparable to losing a loved one  it's a nice way of putting it  [Music]  you  [Music]  you